[MUSIC PLAYING]
The presence of great role
models, which honestly I
think like combined
with the fact
that MIT'S arts programs
are available to everyone,
and not just people who
have a sheet of paper that
says they're in an arts major.
Those two things like
really helped me personally,
and I think a lot
of other people too.
My experience of getting
off doing improv,
I mean like improvising when I
sing jazz is just like, I think
the first step is you
just have to get over,
you have to get over yourself.
Improvisation is a good
part of any theater.
The highest risk improvisation
is during performances
when someone doesn't
have something
they're supposed to have,
or one light turns pink.
That was a really fun one.
I think it's really
important to create
spaces that welcome failure.
Because for me, like when
I first jumped into art,
like I was making things
I had never made before.
And obviously as an
artist, as you grow,
you're definitely going to
look back on your past work
and be like wow that
is honestly awful.
And Infinite and definitely
this organization, that's
what's happening
and that's what's
allowing people to
grow and continue
to allow new people to come
in so that when we leave,
there are people who
have grown and outgrown
and can continue leading.